[Music]
let's go to lauren in springfield
illinois lauren what are you doing
yo
i am cleaning someone else's house
[Laughter]
hey
uh do you have the permission to be in
there
yes actually
this time this call would have been such
a better call if you're like no i broke
in
i thought we were on something okay i i
never have done this i don't think i
don't remember on the show
um kelly gave me
the kelly jenna gave me
your email
can i read it yeah go for it
here's what
here's what you wrote
i always get like a sentence or two
that's like
like hey this call may be about this
especially if it's like
um i've got some diagnos i got ocd i've
got narcissism disorder whatever
so that i can make sure i'm calling the
right experts to make sure i know what
i'm talking about
this one she just gave me the email here
it reads
i feel by the way
this call should be we should be
sponsored today by
the everyone's favorite drink in a bag
capri sun
[Music]
i feel like i'm a capri sun
and my husband daughter and even my dog
all have straws
yes
i'm feeling overworked out touched
and exhausted
i want to meet the needs of my family
without feeling drained in the process
can you help me work through this
dude email of the day
really
well i mean it's not like a contest with
points but you did go oh no you did good
tell me what's going on that's such a
it's an incredible picture you painted
for me
i'm very descriptive i think i try to be
very descriptive i love it everything
i love it um
that was sent at like 2 30 in the
morning one night i was laying in bed
i was like i feel like i'm at my wit's
end so that's when it happened okay and
several things have happened since then
and things have gone a little better no
no no
no
i know people like you
and
you're walking it back because that's
who you are
yes that's true don't walk it back tell
me what's going on
okay
well
i
quit my job after working for almost
seven years as a dental hygienist i quit
and i have decided to start my own
business
and cleaning and getting permission in
people's houses and so you stopped
cleaning people's mouths and you started
cleaning their toilets
what more do you want like it's a it's a
meticulous cleaner
i bet you're amazing at this okay so you
couldn't you quit your business you
started your own job okay yeah yeah and
so i
have an incredible husband i have such a
sweet two and a half year old daughter
and i have a six-year-old boston terrier
and i am everyone's favorite in this
house i am the glue my husband calls me
the glue that holds everybody together
everybody loves to be touched and loved
on and
loves it when the house is clean and
then at the end of the day i just feel
so
exhausted
yeah i feel very drained and i feel bad
that i feel bad that way because i love
them all very much but there's times
where i'm like laying in bed at 2 30 a.m
feeling like a capri sun yeah your body
isn't a wonderland your body's a jungle
gym it might be a wonderland that's not
for me to say but it's a jungle gym so
listen
who told you that your job was to take
care of everybody else that's a that's
an old story you've been playing for a
long time
yeah yeah and you know what i'm the
oldest of four i'm a product of divorce
[Music]
and i'm a peacekeeper there you go so
add is a response to yes to chaos
it's our body's way of making dealing
with chaotic it can be maternal
environments i mean prenatal
environments it can be
um childhood adventures probably both
and in your case
and
god almighty and you also got to play
mom number two right
yeah yeah i did and so my mom
she has high expectations of herself
all the time and i think i translate
that into high expectations of me
and if i don't keep things a certain way
then i feel like i'm letting her down
too i think is what i internalize it as
gotcha so it's just
and then i end up shutting down and just
trying to keep everybody happy is my
default and then i don't realize it
until i'm totally frazzled and then my
husband's probably kind of shocked too
so
yeah that's kind of where i'm at how
long have you all been married
we have been married going on three
years we've been together for about six
and it's been a whirlwind i'll tell you
what we got together and about a year
and a half later we were engaged also
renovating a house also living in it and
then planning a wedding
and then we're like hey let's have a kid
so we did that
so i feel like
there are days i feel like i really
didn't take the time to get to know him
as well as he got to know me
and he doesn't know you
maybe not he doesn't
um that's fair to say
i'm gonna rattle off a series of
questions that i don't want you to
answer
okay okay
when's the last time you said
you've got dinner this week and here's
what i want to eat
when's the last time you said
this is the kind of sex we are having
and i'm taking the lead
when's the last time you said i'm off
bedtime duty for five days in a row
because i'm exhausted
or i need you to be at home and because
i'm going to the gym and i know it's six
o'clock but this is going to be best for
me
those questions sound nuts to you
yeah
okay
and so
your husband has an incredible picture
of a hilarious
super fun
up for anything
wife
he's got a great picture of a
rock star human being someone who will
work themselves until their body's like
and we're out and we're done
yeah it will wake up at 2 a.m with to
remind you of the guilt which is the the
gasoline that keeps the engine running
that engine
ultimately melts together and never runs
again
yeah and that's what i'm afraid of that
ultimately we're we're gonna raise our
daughter and then look at each other and
say who is this person in my house get
out
[Laughter]
or you're going to inadvertently present
a picture to your daughter of this is
what getting through life looks like
and if she happens to have your
um
bubbly joyful personality she'll be able
to fake it too
but she might not she might just be more
of a quiet introvert she might be
someone who likes to
get her head screwed on straight and
then go out into the world and the
world's gonna destroy her for it
yeah and so
the greatest gift and this is going to
sound counterintuitive the greatest gift
you could give your family
is to start answering these questions
what do you want
and what do you need
so that
you can show up and help other people
with what they need
the greatest gift a husband and wife can
give each other is to be really
articulate and clear here's what i need
right now and then the other partner
says here's what i need right now and we
work together to help as best we can
meet each other's needs so that they can
then help meet our needs and then we end
up in this beautiful psych circle like a
wedding band and it never stops and the
needs change over time and the beliefs
change over time and the things that i
think are fun or not fun change over
time things i think are sexy and not
sexy change over time but we keep
showing up and saying all right what do
you need in this season what do you need
in this season and here's what i need in
this season and you leave out the other
part of that equation
yeah
yeah that's true and i don't want to
it's not to blame your you're you never
blame the two and a half year old
they're just two and a half they don't
know
um and i'm not going to blame your
husband he just sounds like he's a great
human being this is just the deal he
signed up for this will be weird
it will be different and
the men i've talked to and this is me
too included
think the end of the world has come
when their
wife starts speaking up
and it's much better to speak up
because you
desire it not because i have to or i'm
going to end up in ashes you know what
i'm saying you can own this or it just
happens
all right usually after kid number two
or three
and somebody's on the brink of an affair
or whatever like we are
somebody loses a job and then it all
comes out
it sounds like you're not quite there
yet you're on the front end of this deal
that you can say hey
i've kept what i need quiet for a long
time and you're such an amazing partner
here
here's what i'm gonna start practicing
speaking up for needs these are called
boundaries by the way i'm gonna start
speaking up for these things along the
way
and
will you work with me on this
invite him into this my guess is he's
gonna be all about it
yeah yeah he's really good about he's
always like just say what you need
that's what i struggle with that's right
okay so give me a couple of hints
nope not a couple of hints give me a
couple of things
hold on
you were not allowed to tell your mom
what you needed
because what you needed didn't matter
nobody cares right
and your three knuckleheaded brothers do
you have all brothers
i have a brother and a sister and
another brother a younger brother that
was in the next marriage yeah okay oh
that's even more fun right
that's a whole nother that's a whole
other call exactly
so
um they could give the five box of farts
what your needs were they don't care
right and so
saying your needs out loud got you in
trouble
it hurt you your body had learned over
time do not say these things out loud
because we're not allowed to
and so you're gonna have to fight your
own body for a season and don't not
physically but you're gonna have to walk
alongside yourself as you learn how to
say things out loud because your body's
gonna say if you say that out loud he
might leave
if you say a need out loud he might say
i'm not doing that
probably he won't but that's gonna that
weight is gonna be so
a lot you know what i'm saying yeah yeah
yeah and so i already feel it i know you
do so
practice with me
give me a couple of needs
i need
to go to bed and the dishes are done
okay and the living room looks like
nobody lives there so every morning i
wake up it's like a fresh start okay
and
so let's let's drill into that one need
what's one step below that so what does
that mean
so
that means you know he works a later
shift than i do no no no no
annie and i are in her bed and he comes
home and he does have time to be able to
do that and so when i wake up
um and it's things aren't done i'm like
oh well you had a golden opportunity
brother does he know that
i've said it in the past that i don't
think it got through or it wasn't said
the way it was most meaningful probably
so clear is kind
here's the best way to have this
conversation
i'm practicing
saying my needs out loud and this is
hard for me because i've never done it
and mom used to get really like wouldn't
hear it so i love you and we're gonna
practice this together is that cool and
he'll say that's cool of course
and say
from the hours of six to nine o'clock
i have
to feed a kid
feed an adult
feed two adults
we've got dishes we've got house
gotta get this kid
bathed which is at two and a half feel
by the way that that changes in a few
years it's so great when they just start
bathing themselves it's like you get
your whole life back it's coming okay
hang in there but i gotta bathe a kid
i also need
whether you think so or not i need the
house like for me to sleep i need the
house to be clean
and that's also the time we do it
so
there's only so many minutes
i can
spend time here i can spend time here or
i can spend time here
and
if he's like most men i know he'll be
like
sweet consider the dishes done i'll even
right we can figure some of that out and
by the way
some days
my body has been in service to this two
and a half year old
and so it is not going to be up for in
service to a
29 year old too
i need my body back
okay yeah i feel that i've breastfed for
way too long man i'll tell you what no
longer anymore obviously but
i will feel like obviously i got out of
that why all kinds of people call this
show yeah yeah right true you're just
getting it back yeah
you're just getting it back and
that's a whole other phone call too but
all that to say is this
practice speaking your needs out and
practice being very very clear
um this is also a great time for him to
have permission to say his needs out out
loud too
and so
this is when you can say okay cool we're
going to start putting
cleaning on the calendar
or our night time routine you're gonna
take a lap around the house make sure
the dishes are up make sure the counters
are wiped off and make sure the living
room is cleaned up
it's gonna take literally seven minutes
to do those three things seven minutes
and your wife gets to have a full night
of sleep
right right and he's gonna say
i need it's been two and a half years i
need more intimate time with you great
we're gonna put that on the calendar
monday wednesday friday you can think
about it all day i'll even send you
weird text if you like whatever we're
going to think about like but we're
going to put on the calendar that way
we're both on the same page here then
your needs are going to allow me to meet
your needs and then my needs are going
to allow you to meet so and now we're
working together you hear what i'm
saying
yeah and then we both give a little then
one of us won't be trying to give
everything
you know well if you both give a lot in
service to each other true then you're
you see what i'm saying
yeah right now you're having to survive
because everyone's draining you
let's flip that thing around and while
you're filling other people up he has
now plugged his straw back well that's
uh that this is gonna get awful so i'm
just gonna leave it there he is helping
you and you're helping him how about
that
yeah is that cool yeah all right yeah so
here's the here's the step forward
you initiate it
because it's gonna be hard for you this
is the homework assignment you initiate
the call
there's a conversation you say
saturday morning i'm getting a
babysitter you and me are going to
breakfast and we're going to talk about
needs
so his homework assignment over the next
48 hours
is to write down like some needs that he
has
some things that that bring him life to
bring him joy to bring him connection to
bring him peace
and you will bring yours and yours are
not less than because
he's gonna say things like i need to
hold the baby and you're gonna say like
i need the dishes done
all of the needs count all of them
and then we're gonna sit down and say
okay let's get an actual calendar and
see how we can make this work let's see
how we can make this work let's do this
together and then we're going to
practice it because there's going to be
a night he forgets to do the dishes and
you're going to wake up and think oh my
husband hates me he does and he forgot
you're going to remind him and he's
going to go ah i know i know i know and
he's going to get it done and then
there's going to be a night that's a
wednesday night and he's got a starbucks
you're gonna be like dude i'm so tired
and he's gonna be like but we had on the
calendar and you'll be like i can't i
know okay we're we're going to practice
meeting each other's needs so that
each other can meet each other's needs
so that each other can meet each other's
needs and off into the future together
you
my sister lauren
are amazing and i don't say that lightly
he is lucky to have you your baby girl's
lucky to have your community's lucky to
have you and now i want you to be lucky
you have you
you're worth
saying here's what i need